ちょっとこういう動画は
恥ずかしいですねこんにちははじめしゃ
ちょーです
もうあの後ろにいるんですけど
いつからだっけ
去年
去年ぐらいかなそうだよねあのー
去年から
一緒に
住んでる人がいます
うわぁこれ
言っちゃう今日
いやでもまあお正月というかことし始めだ
からもう今しかもう言うた意味がないかな
もういっちゃいましょうはいええと3億円
のオムツを買って1年ちょっとぐらい
積んでみて結構広くてこうなんか寂しい
なって思ったり俺もういい年というかね
あのそろそろなんか動かなきゃなと思って
あのちょっと
実は
同棲しております
確実ですすいませんでした
いやマジで申し訳ない本当になんかそれ別
に自分から言うことでもないと思ったし
言ったところでみたいな感じではあると
思うんですけどもやっぱそういうのはこう
報告した方がいいかなと思って動画にさせ
てもらってます
ねそう発芽してねマジか
言うこれ
言うかちょっと今一緒に住んでる人がもう
後ろにいるのでちょっと色々聞いてみたい
と思います今どう一緒に俺と住んで楽しい
あ楽しいああよかったそれはもう
三角
うわちょっと微妙だったら恥ずかしいな
普通に
えーバレたりもしてないの誰かなんか
始めしゃちょーの家に住んでるみたいな
バレてない
あーそっか意外とバレないもんなんだな
広いしいろんな人出入りするしねただ管理
人とかもちゃんと仕事あったら帰ってるし
基本的に何もない時は僕このお家で1人
だったんですけども
えー
実はあの隠してたつもりとかないんです
けども去年の年末
前ぐらいから一緒にこの家で同棲している
方がいます
登場してもらいましょうどうぞ
お前やないかい弟やないかいや恥ずかし
いって
弟やないかぎりですよろしくお願いします
お願いします
一番
恥ずかしいどういうこと
彼女とかだと思うやん
一言そんなこと言ってないので
実はですね今年の
ほんと年末に
完全えどういう感じなの今あなたは
誰でも家がないよね
どういう流れかと言いますと一応僕のなん
かその裏周りを色々やってもらおうと思っ
てるんですけども
実家の富山でもお仕事があるんだよねあり
ます
実家のテーマで仕事しつつそのお仕事が
ちょっとないといけ静岡に来て仕事手伝っ
てもらったりしてるんですけどま静岡に来
た時に家がないとちょっと前まであったん
だよね一応あったね
家借りてたんだけどその家をちょっと
引き払ってせっかく家が大きいんだったら
ここにも住めばいいんじゃないかという
ことで今一緒に住んでます
弟ですよろしくお願いしますよろしくお
願いしますどうですかこの3億円の豪邸で
の生活は
いや
持て余すよね持て余すなんかでかいでかい
よね寂しい寂しいよね
正直2人でいても
全く合わないような生活も全然可能な
ぐらいスペースがあるしずっと住んでいる
わけではなくて富山に行ったりオレンジに
来たりというので行き来してるけども基本
的にはここに今は住んでいるというそう
ですね半々ぐらいで
月の半分あとでお月の半分はこっちって
感じですなるほど
こん中よかったな
俺も女が良かったどうするこれ男2人で
済んだらもうさーいろいろと遠のいちゃう
よねいつ結婚するの
で部屋をもうちゃんとひと部屋バーンて
渡したので
トリプラスちょっとお正月とかに家も色々
改造したというかちょっと配置とかも変え
たので久々にはじめしゃちょーが3億円の
ルームツアーやっていきたいと思いますで
いきましょう
1回の玄関はそんなに変わりませんいつも
通りの俺の家ただ奥に進んで1階のお部屋
撮影したり編集してたり色々あったんです
けども今はここはもう完全に
撮影部屋にしようかなと思ってますここに
カメラ置いてこういう感じで
取れたらいいかなと思ってます
[音楽]
でもうね俺はね思った遊びと撮影を
切り離してはいけないなんか撮影スペース
で決めちゃうと
頭が固くなって撮影しなきゃみたいなのに
なっちゃうからもう
遊びな場所と撮影の場所を一緒にしようと
いうことでここはもう完全に遊びの
スペーストさせていただきましたここが
完全に遊びのスペースですなんかごろっと
寝れもしますしもうここで日々スマブラも
しております
生活感出まくりでやばい
僕は完全にもう俺の遊びスペースだな遊び
じゃ撮影を切り離してはいけない
YouTubeは人生だはい2回来ました
一番広いスペースですねここはね広すぎて
やだもう広すぎてなんか
物を大量に買っても場所が広すぎて目立た
ないとかちょっと色々分かったことがあっ
た前までここで撮影してなんですけどここ
もなんか
なんかね
誰かあげるお前控え室みたいな感じかな誰
か来たらここに適当にポイって放り込もう
2階のキッチンはなんか料理とかそういう
ことする時はこの部屋を使おうかなと思っ
ております以上さあここで皆さん思った
はずです
編集どうした編集どうしたそう編集どうし
た編集する場所は今のところないと思うん
ですけども編集する場所と3階にセットさ
せていただきました
[音楽]
なんか
実は12月末にやっと前部屋ネット通り
ました
逆に逆に守って全員が通ってなかっ
たっていう話になるんですけども撮って
ませんでした実は1回と4回ですかネット
通ってなくてようやく2回3回ネット取っ
たことによって全ての部屋でネットが
使える作業ができ
るっていうことになったので改めて
ちょっと前までコンビニの部屋だったかな
コンビニの部屋になってた部屋が今編集
部屋になってます
撮影は撮影でしっかり楽しくやって編集は
ここでバシッとするという感じの部屋に
なってますここが寝室になってますもう俺
の服とかもここに基本置いてあるしなんか
後輩とか来たらここに寝ちゃうって感じか
な
[音楽]
[拍手]
ディディーコングなんてこと
励ましおめでとうございます今年も
よろしくお願いしますあいやそんな
申し訳ないですか行きましょうそして4階
ですね4
階はもうなんか管理室みたいな感じですね
映ってはいけないもの写っていけない人
そういう人が集まっておりますこの企画で
最近使ったお菓子が山積みになってます
マジで多すぎて困ってますお疲れ様ですお
疲れ様です
[音楽]
だいたいこんな感じかなでちょっと前まで
4回の多くの部屋がなんか俺の
プライベートルームみたいな感じなんです
けどもそこをですねなんと今
完全に完全に
弟の部屋になってます俺のこことかも全部
弟に今使わせようと思って弟の部屋になっ
てます
ないや
失礼いたしましたという感じのお部屋に
なっておりますしっかり生活する人が一人
増えるだけで結構
場所の使い方変わるかなって思いました
12回目メインで撮影して3回で編集
しっかりやっていこうかなと思ってます
はい結構進化しましたようやくネットが
完備されたということでまだまだ今年も
3億円の部屋改造していきつつ
弟も住んでいるということで
[音楽]
移動の足につか仲良くして生活していき
たいと思います
以上
[音楽]